las inundaciones en kentucky siguen
cobrando vidas el gobernador a debe ser
quien declaró el estado de emergencia en
el estado advirtió que la cifra podría
aumentar neus es sexting enfermedades
son noticias difíciles 16 muertes
confirmadas hasta ahora y la cifra va a
aumentar mucho más esto en cuatro
condados varios en el condado de perry
una mujer de 81 años 11 de ellos hasta
ahora estar en el condado de not
incluido un hombre de 63 años una mujer
de 65 años y dos niños
es que las lluvias torrenciales causan
devastación a su paso unos 23.000
hogares y negocios están sin
electricidad las carreteras parecían
ríos en la región de los apalaches
los afectados esperaban ayuda desde los
tejados de sus casas presumen
tuvimos que salir nadando y hacía frío
estaba por encima de mi cabeza así que
daba miedo
los bomberos luchan para ayudar a los
afectados la guardia nacional y la
policía estatal utilizaron helicópteros
y barcos para rescatar a decenas de
personas de sus casas y vehículos
ver videos no es malo realmente lo es
llevo casi 27 años como bombero y esto
es lo peor que he visto nunca la gente
no se encuentra probablemente el 95% de
la gente de esta zona lo ha perdido todo
casas coches animales es desgarrador
realmente lo es
pero la emergencia no es solo enfrenta
aquí en las vegas nevadas las lluvias
inundaron las calles y algunos casinos
según el servicio metereológico nacional
hay advertencia y avisos de inundación
también en el noreste del estado de
tennessee y al oeste del estado de
virginia